SCOTT ROWE: CSS properties are
some of the most ubiquitous
artifacts in web development.
You can't really develop
anything for the web without
editing its CSS properties.
There are some 500 CSS
properties, though the most
commonly used of these narrow
down to a few hundred.
And it is these most commonly
used properties that we aim to
document for the beta release
of Web Platform Docs.
And we're excited to have
third parties like Adobe
Brackets and Chrome Dev Tools
using this information in
their products.
This video serves to supplement
the information
you'll find on the CSS property
project pages.
In other words, yes, you'll
still need to read the Web
Platform Wednesday Doc and the
CSS Property Editing Guide to
be prepared to contribute
to this project.
Once you're ready to start,
visit the Web Platform
Wednesday page to choose
some properties and
tasks to work on.
Every Wednesday at 11 o'clock AM
Pacific time, seven o'clock
PM UTC, we gather on the free
node IRC channel #webplatform
to go over the list
of properties
designated for the week.
You can either post to the
channel with the properties
and tasks you want to work on,
or you can send an email to
public-webplatform @w3.org.
You'll be contacted by a
coordinator who will help you
work on the project.
But you don't have
to wait until
Wednesday to get involved.
Send an email any time.
Wherever possible, choose a
group of related properties,
so you can take advantage of any
cut and paste shortcuts.
For example, Rob Simpson has
signed up to work on several
text decoration properties.
He sent an email to
public-webplatform@w3.org, and
coordinator Julie edited the
table to sign him up.
You won't need to
edit this table.
Just stay in contact with the
coordinator as you work, and
the coordinator will update
all the record keeping.
Often you'll have a group of
related properties that
includes a shorthand property.
Think of the shorthand property
as the master
property of the group.
For example, the text decoration
property is the
shorthand property for the text
decoration color, text
decoration line, and text
decoration style CSS
properties.
Once the coordinator has
signed you up for the
property, click on the link
in the table and open the
Properties page.
If the link is red or the page
does not exist, contact the
coordinator.
If your group of articles
includes a shorthand property,
work on the page for the
shorthand property first.
You'll need to refer to
the w3 specifications.
Pull up the specs cited in the
fourth column of the table,
then search the page for the
property you were working on.
Ah, they moved it to
a different spec.
This sort of thing happens
a lot with specs.
They're constantly changing.
Also be sure you're referring
to the most up to date spec.
At the top of the specification
page, there are
listed all of the pertinent
versions.
Use the latest editor's
draft spec.
In page search is your
best friend.
Notice that the shorthand
property is described after
its component properties.
This is typical.
Note also that the specs contain
a lot of superfluous
information.
This is because they are
intended primarily for browser
developers who are implementing
the standard, not
necessarily for application
developers and designers using
the standard.
Your job is to distill from all
of this information just
what a developer or designer
needs to use the property in
an application.
We'll go over how to include
this information in your dock
a little bit later
in the video.
However, not all the information
about the property
may be found in the spec.
Review other documentation
sources for more information
and to get familiar
with the property.
As you find information in other
sources, be careful to
use it only in a manner that
does not violate any
copyrights or license
restrictions.
Don't plagiarize.
In Web Platform Docs, we
always provide content
attribution when information
is drawn
from external sources.
See the Editor's Guide for more
information about license
and copyright issues and
external attribution.
We'll go over external
attribution in greater detail
later in this video.
While CSS properties are the
focus of Web Platform
Wednesdays, you can sign up to
work on specific tasks for CSS
property pages, or you can sign
up for all tasks on a
given page.
The tasks are documenting basic
facts, explanatory text,
creating examples, links, and
reviewing complete articles.
The basic facts include the
values in the overview table,
the syntax, and the
property values.
You can copy and paste these
values and descriptions from
the specs as they are.
The spec says for the animatable
value, see
individual properties.
Usually if all of the longhand
properties are animatable, the
associated shorthand property
is animatable too.
You should always test it.
Ask the coordinator if you need
help testing properties
for animation.
For the CSS object model
property, this is usually the
same name as the property with
the hyphens removed and the
words combined with camelCase,
as shown here.
By the way, you can ignore
the percentages field.
Notice that the border style
value none has a link to more
information about background
image here in the W3C spec.
Be sure to pull all that
information into your
documentation.
In this example, that the image
layer counts, but is not
drawn when the value is none,
and include a link to the
related WPD page, in this
example, the background image
CSS property page.
In other words, be sure to
include all relevant
supplementary information in
the value descriptions.
Notice also that we use code
formatting to style the text
for other property
values described.
In the hidden property value
description, the words none
and hidden are formatted as
code to set them off from
ordinary text.
Once you have all the values
documented, the syntax section
displays them as code syntax
automatically.
The explanatory text in the
summary, usage, and note
sections is where you
will contribute to
your original content.
You will contribute your
original content gleaned from
your research in the specs and
related documentation.
Here, it is really important
that you contribute only
original content.
No cutting and pasting verbatim
from other sources.
The article summary should
briefly describe the property.
If the property is a shorthand
property, the summary should
say so and link to all of the
properties associated with the
shorthand property.
The usage section provides
guidelines for using the
property and any little gotchas
not obvious in the
descriptions.
Notes describe considerations
for how the property works,
usually beyond the
user's control.
Don't worry about the important
notes section.
This is just an artifact from
the initial content import.
Now for the funnest part,
the examples.
Keep these super simple.
Save the complex, fancy examples
for a tutorial
another day.
Your example should demonstrate
this property only.
Don't introduce other properties
or make the example
dependent upon the knowledge
of other properties.
Also, the example should
be self explanatory.
To create an example, start
with a new codelet at
code.webplatform.org.
First, I save as new to
create a new codelet.
This will assign a file
name to the codelet.
Then I replace the dummy
content with my own.
You should test your example in
all of the major browsers.
Watch out for deviations
from the spec
when you run the example.
It turns out that dotted lines
in Chrome are composed of
square dots instead of round
ones, as they are in Firefox.
I'll go back and adjust the
description accordingly.
We want to catch and document
these little deviances and
details wherever we find them.
In this example, I've
set up an element to
demonstrate each value.
However, you can also set up
your examples to be more
interactive.
In this example, the values for
the property are provided
in the comments, so a
user can just plug
them in and play around.
But that's about as complicated
as you should make
your example.
Don't get carried away with
creating drop-down menus for
all the values, or otherwise
building a playground up here.
That will only clutter the code
and distract the user.
Once you have a nice working
example, copy the pertinent
code back into the page
for the property you
were working on.
Notice I'm only including the
CSS code, not the HTML, here
in the CSS property
documentation.
Also, copy the URL from the
codelet example to the live
example URL field, which will be
the value for the View Live
Example link in the
published doc.
To create a link to the W3C
specification, under related
specifications, copy and paste
the title of the specification
into the name field, the URL
for the spec into the URL
field, and the status level
into the status field.
Some properties belong to more
than one specification, so be
sure to include references
to each specification.
You can skip the compatibility
sections.
We're replacing these
with automated data.
In the see also section,
skip topic clusters.
These two are getting
an overhaul.
In the manual links field,
include cross references to
related CSS properties and other
internal resources, such
as tutorials from the
CSS tutorials page.
In the external links field,
include any references to
relevant external content.
In the topic section, check
the box for CSS.
Don't check any other boxes.
In the external attribution
section, leave any checked
boxes the way they are.
And if any of the content you
contributed came from an
external source, check the box
for that source and include
the link to the source
in the link field.
That's it for the
edits for now.
Remember, you can always come
back later and edit some more
in case you remember something
you've forgotten.
If you are not the reviewer, be
sure the needs review check
box in the high level issue
section is checked.
If you are the reviewer, make
any corrections or additions
to the content as needed.
Once your review is complete,
uncheck the needs
review check box.
If any other high level issues
check boxes are checked,
please resolve the issue and
uncheck the box or note the
issue for your report back to
the coordinator for Web
Platform Wednesdays.
When you're all done editing
a page, under edit details,
enter a summary of the
work you've performed
and click save page.
If you're working on CSS
properties as part of Web
Platform Wednesday, be sure to
note how much time you spent
on any particular property and
report that back to the
coordinator.
Also note any issues or concerns
you have with the
content and report that
back as well.
Also please, please, please
tweet, post, or otherwise
communicate through social media
channels like Facebook
and G+ and Twitter.
We want to get the word out.
And that completes
the exercise.
Thanks for contributing.
Your time and expertise
are invaluable.
And your contribution to Web
Platform Docs and the greater
community is making the
web successful.